foreign
[Applause]
there
foreign
okay hi everybody
um so my name is Nicole wine I am one of
the fellows this semester and next
semester I'll start as an assistant
professor at University of Michigan
um so this talk that I'll give right now
will have no technical content
essentially I don't think I'll even
State any results what I'm going to do
is basically State a bunch of problems
and my hope is that if you find any
overlap with
um the type of problems that I like then
we can talk
okay so what I'm going to be doing is
kind of like filling in this chart these
are three research areas that I've
worked in and that I like a lot so one
of them is about shortest paths and also
includes some kind of structural
existential shortest path type problems
this one is for dynamic and also Online
problems so this is when like your input
is changing over time and you need to
get an algorithm that copes with this
changing input and the third one is like
fine-grained complexity and reductions
between different problems to show
hardness
um and then for each of these I will
write some problems that I've worked on
in the past and then also some of the
problems that I like
um but before I go into any of this I
want to First tell you about a specific
problem that I'm working on right now
um and
if you're interested in this problem
come talk to me this is a thing where
like we have some partial results and I
think we probably need some more ideas
to get over the finish line and um would
be interested in working with people
here if you're interested in this
problem so okay this is the problem
called the Vantage Point selection
problem
if you think you've heard of this
problem you haven't heard of the version
that I'm about to say because it hasn't
been published at all so there's one
paper about this problem not by me but
by others and it's not online yet and
they defined this problem based on a
connection to like they worked with like
networking people and Define so this is
like a shortest path type theoretical
combinatorial problem that was motivated
originally by like some networking
application of like finding bottleneck
capacity edges in the internet
okay so here's the problem
so we have a graph and we also have that
each Edge has an unknown capacity so
these numbers are capacities they're not
weights The Edge the graph might also be
weighted but I'm just ignoring the
weights for the Simplicity of this
picture and what we can do as the
algorithm is we know the entire graph
but we don't know these capacities and
we're basically trying to discover what
these capacities are
and what can we do to query the graph we
can query an individual vertex and it
gives us the following information
so it reveals for each every other
vertex U
what is the capacity of the Min capacity
Edge on the shortest path from V to U
so let's assume that there are unique
shortest paths between any pair of
vertices and let's say this is you for
example and this is the shortest path
from vdu then it will reveal the minimum
capacity Edge which in this case is 2
because 2 is smaller than 6. and so
similarly like If This Were you it would
reveal this Edge and what happens when
you query V is that it reveals for all
of the U in the graph this minimum Edge
and so these pink
bold numbers are what it would reveal if
you query V
in particular like this one would not be
revealed because if when you when this
is you the minimum capacity Edge on this
path is three instead of four did that
does that make sense so far the
definition of what it means to query
something
okay so then once you so then what is
our goal our goal is to like query
vertices in the graph so that we are
revealing many edges in the graph and in
particular what we would like to do is
the following so let's let opt be the
max number of edges that you could
reveal over all possible queries
so the best vertex I could possibly
query how many edges does that reveal
and what I would like to do now is to
bound the number of queries that I need
in order to reveal order opt edges
and my algorithm of course doesn't know
the capacities ahead of time
a single query
yes
okay yes when you revealed you also
reveal the The Edge or just a capacity
of that edge
so I know all of the edges ahead of time
like I already know the entire graph it
does that answer your question so when
you repeat that the main capacities too
do I know that oh yes yes I know this
particular address
capacity to yes thank you okay
just checking shortest pass this number
of edges nothing about the capacities
one more time uh the shortest path is
just the number of edges not the nothing
about the capacities uh yes the shortest
path can be on number of edges or there
could be underlying weights which you'll
find stuff and has nothing to do
uh let's assume it's Unique
okay good so that's the end of uh this
question and one kind of cool thing
about this problem is that we actually
don't know anything true non-trivial
about it
um
let's talk afterwards if you're
interested in knowing like what are the
trivial bounds and what we're trying to
achieve here but this is like a very
open problem
okay so now back to
um more of an overview of the types of
problems that I like so let's start with
this section so these are past problems
I've worked on in the area of shortest
paths
um oh and one more thing I also like in
general combinatorial problems that
arise from different application domains
such as the problem you just heard about
so for this one
um one thing I've worked on is like
these structural problems of spanners
and hop sets which is something Jason
mentioned as well so these are problems
of like I'm given a graph and I want to
sparsify it while preserving the
approximate distances in the graph
that's what a spanner is and a hops that
is a related notion where we're trying
to
actually kind of do the opposite add
edges to the graph so that the you can
get from anywhere to anywhere else in
only a few number of hops while again
preserving approximate distances
and there are a bunch of these problems
in like structural graph
Theory which is where we ask the
question of given a graph can I simplify
it in some sense while preserving some
important property of it and just like
last week we submitted a paper to itcs
uh introducing a new problem that is
under this umbrella so what we do here
is like preserve the structure of the
shortest paths in the graph where the
goal is to minimize the edge weights in
the graph
happy to talk more about that after
this is another recent paper that was
also submitted to iccs about uh disjoint
the disjoint shortest paths problem
and then now for some open problems here
that I like one of them is the kind of
curious not shortest path problem in
directed graphs so this is a problem
that's actually if you've been on the
second floor and you've seen the
whiteboards up there it's written up
there it was written up there by my
former PhD advisor Virginia Williams and
when I was a student we worked on this
problem together and I think it's a
interesting problem the problem is
exactly what it sounds like you're given
an unweighted directed graph you're
given a source and sync pair S T and you
just want to know give me a path from s
to T that is not a shortest path and we
don't even know if there's a polynomial
time algorithm for this problem it's the
question is I guess prove NP hardness or
show polynomial time
there's and it's known for undirected
graphs that you can get it in polynomial
time
there's another problem that kind of
Falls in a similar category where we
don't know if it's in P or not and again
it's a problem on directed graphs
um where it is known to be in P for the
undirected version and this is the K
disjoint shortest paths problem
and in this problem we're given a set of
K Source sync pairs S1 T1 s2t2s3 T3 Etc
and what we want to do is find shortest
paths between each pair of terminals
and we want them to all be disjoint
this is not to be confused with a
similar problem which says among all
disjoint paths which one is the shortest
we're not trying to do that that's
already known to be hard this is every
single individual path must individually
be shortest and maybe it's not possible
so in some cases you would just return
no you cannot do this but if it is
possible then I want to return what are
these shortest disjoint paths and it's
not known to be in P in particular for
constant k for example three disjoint
paths is not known
Okay so now let me move on to the second
category so here's a few problems that
I've worked on in the dynamic and online
settings in the dynamic one these are
just some very classical problems like
coloring independent set shortest paths
and in general the model for dynamic
algorithms is I'm given a graph and
edges are being inserted and deleted
from the graph and I need to return for
example
a coloring of the graph after every
single update
for Online problems I've recently worked
on this like data structures problem
called online list labeling which I
won't mention here but in general I like
Online problems and data structures
problems
now let me tell you about my favorite
probably open problem that falls into
this
um rectangle which is the dynamic Edge
orientation problem
so in this problem I'm going to state to
you the simplest version of it that is
not known
and the simplest version of it is kind
of deceptively simple in that the input
is literally just a tree so we have a
tree
and it's Dynamic and so at every Point
like at every point in time there's
going to be an edge that's added or
deleted but we have the promise that at
every point in time it's always going to
be a forest
and what we would like to do is to
orient each one of these edges in such a
way
that the out degree of every vertex is a
constant so for example here's an
orientation this orientation has maximum
out degree two but in general
you can get maximum out degree one by
just saying let's pick a root and let's
direct all of the edges up towards the
root
but the challenge here is to maintain it
dynamically so subject to Edge
insertions and deletions we may need to
sometimes change the orientation of some
edges so for example this could be
deleted this could be inserted and we
might need to change the orientation of
some edges and the question is
essentially comes down to how many Edge
orientation flips do we need to do per
update
there are some non-trivial bounds known
for this problem but there's still uh
large gaps and in particular
the answer could be constant we don't
know the best is log n but it could be
the case that you only need like a
constant number of edge flips which
would be pretty cool regardless of the
size of the graph
um one cool thing about this problem is
that if you were able to improve this it
is used as a subroutine in many other
papers and so
um it would directly improve the running
times of a number of different
problems in the area of dynamic
algorithms specifically on graphs that
have bounded arboricity or degeneracy
okay so now for the last one my main
focus here has been on doing
fine-grained reductions and conditional
hardness for problems about approximate
diameter so diameter being what is the
largest distance in the whole graph and
we would like to get an approximate
answer for this
and
um there's kind of a series of different
reductions and related problems and a
whole family of results around this and
this is this was the main focus of my
PhD thesis a couple years ago so if
you're interested in open problems then
you can take a look at the open problems
page of my PhD thesis
and uh that's the end thank you
[Applause]
questions
so for the not directed party I want a
yes no question is simply asking given a
director enough an smt are all Paths of
the same thing that's that's the problem
yes
um
all simple maths
that's it I have now heard so I know
definitely it's not known if you want to
find a not shortest path
detecting whether or not there is a not
shortest path
I think that's also not known I'm not
thank you
in this in the the question of dynamic
Azure orientation you said it's login is
that only for three so that's known for
some larger category of graphs it's
known for graphs
so if AKA bounded degeneracy so for this
class this is like defined as the class
of graphs that
such that there exists an energy
orientation with founded out degree and
so if if you have a graph from this
class and let's end it and it allows you
to do constant out degree uh then you
can dynamically achieve also login
advertised
actually there have been some worst case
results as well but the question the
open question is about amortized
is this assuming like
infinite running time or like yeah so
great question so you're asking like
because I stated it in terms of how many
Edge splits do you need right so it
turns out there has already been this is
a very interesting thing about this
problem so it turns out that we already
know an optimal algorithm up to constant
factors we just don't know how to
analyze it and so if you could show that
the number of flips is bounded it would
immediately imply that there is an
algorithm that achieves that number
so that was very
cool existence
okay well thanks a lot
[Applause]